[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Wedding cakes
have become bigger and more
elaborate over the years.
Today's wedding
cakes are multitiered
and even multiflavored.
They're typically
covered in fondant icing
and decorated with
ornate sugar flowers.
The finished product is
an edible work of art,
perfect for that special day.
These customized wedding
cakes are covered in fondant.
The specializing
acts as a canvas
on which delicious
designs can be created.
The baker starts
by making chocolate
cakes for the bottom tier.
Once the cakes come
out of the oven,
she transfers them
directly to the fridge.
The cool, firm cakes are
easy to slice into layers.
She spreads buttercream
frosting between the layers.
The frosting ingredients include
lightly salted butter, icing
sugar, and Dutch cocoa powder.
Layer by layer, she builds the
tier to the desired height.
She puts the tier
back in the fridge.
While it's
solidifying, she makes
the gum paste that will be used
to craft the edible flowers.
First, she adds icing
sugar to egg whites.
Then thins out the mixture
with a teaspoon of water.
Next, she adds food coloring.
She mixes the ingredients
for a couple of minutes
until they're
thoroughly blended.
She adds tylose powder, a
synthetic version of gum Arabic
to harden the mixture.
After another 15
seconds of mixing,
the gum paste is
ready for kneading.
The baker rubs some
vegetable shortening
on her hands for lubrication.
She sprinkles some icing
sugar on the table to prevent
the gum paste from sticking.
Then she kneads the gum
paste for 5 to 10 minutes.
Now, the artistry begins.
She uses a set of
modeling tools made
of food-safe, nonstick plastic.
First, she makes a little hat
out of the pink gum paste,
then she rolls out another
piece until it's paper thin.
The baker uses a gum
paste cutter to cut
out several teardrop shapes.
One at a time, she
lays the teardrops
out on a hard foam mat.
She thins and curls
the edges with a ball
tipped modeling tool to create
a natural-looking rose petal.
Then she switches
to a scribe tool.
She curls back the edges to make
the petal even more lifelike.
Then she applies
tasteless edible glue.
She adheres the first
petal along to the point
of the gum paste hat.
She wraps it all the
way around to create
the center of the rose.
The baker attaches
the next layer,
this time using two petals.
She adds several
additional layers
using two more petals each time
until the rose is complete.
She snips off the
base of the hat,
then lets the glue
dry for 15 minutes.
The baker uses green gum
paste to make the leaves.
She rolls the paste thicker
at the base and thinner
at the top.
Then she presses the sheet
against the top of the board
to produce vertical veins.
She centers her leaf shape
cutter over one of the veins
and cuts out a leaf.
After attaching a
wire to the base,
she uses a silicone
stamp to imprint
smaller veins on the leaf.
This makes it look
more realistic.
The baker curls the leaf's
edges with a round tool.
She uses a different tool to
deepen some of the veining
and complete the leaf.
The baker sets her decorations
aside and removes the cake
tiers from the refrigerator.
She firmly applies the fondant
over the chilled chocolate
frosting.
She made the fondant earlier
with melted marshmallows,
butter, icing, sugar, vanilla
extract, and food coloring.
She applies fondant to
the remaining tiers,
then stacks them.
She begins decorating this cake
with ribbon and Italian lace.
She attaches the flowers
with stiff edible glue
made from egg whites, icing,
sugar, and lemon juice.
She can also make
edible ribbons and lace
by pouring liquid gum paste
into the appropriate molds.
This special gum paste uses
corn syrup and cornstarch
to reach the right consistency.
A magnificent custom-made
cake is designed
to be a showpiece at the wedding
reception-- admired, devoured,
and always remembered.